six weeks to the day of Olivia Pratt
corbell's death the man accused of her
murder was brought to court in Liverpool
34 year old Thomas Cashman lives just
two miles from Olivia's home where late
that August night he's alleged to have
shot and killed her the nine-year-old
died from a gunshot wound to the chest
her death sending a wave of shock
through the community and across the
country and sparking a huge
investigation
police said a convicted burglar called
Joseph knee had forced his way into the
family home after seeing Olivia's mother
Cheryl had opened the front door a
gunman fired several shots into the
house killing Olivia Thomas Cashman is
also accused of the attempted murder of
Cheryl and knee and the possession of
firearms with the intent to endanger
life
also in court were members of Olivia's
family including her Father John and her
mother Cheryl throughout proceedings
they stared across the courtroom at
Thomas Cashman in the dock he sat head
bowed at times handcuffed and surrounded
by police officers he said nothing
Beyond confirming his identity
a second man also appeared in court
charged with assisting an offender
40-year-old Paul Russell is alleged to
have driven the gunman away from the
scene that night and disposed of his
clothing
the community Olivia called home
continues to mourn her death merseyside
police have thanked the public for what
they call their overwhelming support of
the investigation an investigation they
say that continues
Thomas Cashman was driven from Court
having been remanded in custody he was
told he will stand trial for Olivia's
murder in March Greg Milam Sky News
Liverpool